i
ah
[Música]
el 12 de enero frente a personas de
cuenca ecuador y latinoamérica dimos el
discurso de apertura de un evento que
gracias a un equipo increíble de
personas pasó de ser una conferencia que
van a y yo teníamos planeada para 40
personas a una comunidad de 800 líderes
despiertos nosotros sabíamos que
queríamos devolver de alguna manera
todas las oportunidades que habíamos
recibido en la ciudad en la que nacimos
pero exactamente como llegamos a ese
punto después de reflexionar sobre
nuestro trayecto llegamos a una
conclusión conciencia
el diccionario define este término tan
abstracto como el conocimiento que el
ser humano tiene de su propia existencia
de sus estados y de sus actos hoy
estamos aquí para compartirles una
fórmula secreta que descubrimos en este
camino por intentar despertar están
listos
no
tranquilos no estamos diciendo que es
algo tan difícil como ser un director de
cine famoso y ganar un oscar es algo
mucho más posible como ser gemela no en
verdad aunque nos encantaría que todo lo
que dicen sobre las gemelas sea verdad
no tenemos ningún poder como leer nos la
mente y tampoco creemos que existen
fórmulas mágicas para despertar cada
persona vive este proceso de manera
diferente lo que sí logramos de
identificar a través de nuestra historia
personal es un proceso con tres pasos
sencillos que se repiten y generan un
ciclo que ayudan a ver el mundo de una
manera diferente el primer paso es un
detonante esa acción o evento externo
que genera una reflexión el segundo paso
es una reflexión que es el
cuestionamiento detallado de todos los
sentimientos y pensamientos que tuvieron
después de haber vivido este detonante y
el tercer paso del círculo de la
conciencia es la acción esa reacción
después de la reflexión
ahora para entender mejor este proceso
les vamos a contar una historia
regresemos cuatro años atrás las dos
teníamos 18 años y nos habíamos graduado
del colegio nos moríamos de ganas de
comernos al mundo pero un miedo
increíble de lo desconocido pensábamos
que el camino a la felicidad era una
línea recta con pasos que ir cumpliendo
como graduarse de una buena universidad
conseguir un buen trabajo en el que nos
paguen bien por ahí conocer un chico
tener una gran familia morir en paz y
estábamos muy bien encaminadas en ese
plan maestro para la vida perfecta
el primer paso entrar a una buena
universidad sek pero aquí vienen los
primeros detonantes el primer año y sin
conocer a nadie nos tocaron dos
compañeras de cuarto la una de china y
la otra gringa yu ling la de china nos
dijo que sus papás querían que se
regrese a hong kong porque ella no logró
entrar a harvard y como en su familia en
la tradición en entrar a esta
prestigiosa universidad para ellos nunca
iba a ser suficiente y por otro lado era
la de eeuu nos contó que sólo después
del segundo intento logra entrar a la
universidad
con un préstamo en el banco que no
terminaría de pagar hasta que sus hijos
tengan hijos y probablemente hasta que
sus hijos se hayan graduado de la
universidad y esto nos llevó a la
siguiente reflexión si el contacto con
realidades tan distintas como la de yu
ling y la de bring nos quisieron poner
en perspectiva nuestro propio estado no
podíamos dejarnos de preguntar qué tan
limitada estaba nuestra noción del mundo
que tantas otras realidades nos faltaban
por conocer y cómo podíamos hacer para
romper esa burbuja en la que habíamos
crecido por eso fuimos en busca de una
experiencia que nos ayude a romper todos
los estereotipos sociales culturales y
religiosos que teníamos creíamos que
íbamos a encontrar la respuesta a
nuestras preguntas en un lugar alejado
que despierten nuestros cinco sentidos y
que nos ayude a tener una nueva
perspectiva y eso nos lleva al
aeropuerto a punto de embarcarnos en un
viaje a la india un viaje de un mes y
medio con un grupo de estudiantes de la
universidad para conocer más sobre
emprendimiento social para mí yo
pensábamos que después de este viaje
a regresar convertidas en la siguiente
madre teresa de calcuta o por lo menos
alcanzar el nirvana sin embargo para
nuestra sorpresa de este viaje no fue
nada como esto que era lo que teníamos
en mente sino más bien algo como esto
una faltada tan fuerte que nos sacudió y
nos dio muchísimas lecciones que no nos
íbamos a olvidar nunca y aquí vienen los
segundos detonantes en la primera semana
fuimos a tilón ya a una escuela nocturna
nuestra profesora nos había dicho que
menos del 50% de niños de línea tienen
acceso a la educación primaria pero no
logramos entender estos números hasta
que conocimos la armh a la mujer que
viene en esa foto una agricultora que
trabajaba todo el día en el campo con
sus hijos y después los llevaba a la
escuela nocturna con la esperanza de
darles un futuro mejor
en la quinta semana fuimos allí vagina
gar un barrio a las afueras de mumbai
construido sobre un botadero de basura
en donde la esperanza de vida es de tan
solo 37 años y en donde viven más de
500.000 personas la población total de
cuenca hay conocimos a shanghai un
costurero que en el ático de su casa
conoce a los saris más hermosos que van
y yo vimos en toda la india
y en la última semana conocimos allí
está una mujer que entró al programa de
ver fútbol leche solar mamás en donde
enseñan a mujeres de comunidades
marginadas a construir paneles solares
cada día en india 2000 niñas son
asesinadas en el vientre materno un poco
después de nacer por el simple hecho de
ser mujeres nunca me voy a olvidar
cuando gitanos dijo ahora que soy yo la
que voy a llevar luz a mi aldea voy a
demostrar que la decisión de mis padres
de traer en al mundo fue la correcta y
esto nos llamó a la siguiente reflexión
todas estas personas nos ayudaron a
entender claramente el privilegio de
nuestra propia existencia porque 500 mil
personas viven en un valle en los andes'
del ecuador mientras otras 500 mil viven
sobre un botadero de basura o porque
nosotras tuvimos la suerte de nacer en
una familia de cinco mujeres cuando en
índia niñas mueren todos los días por el
simple hecho de tener nuestro género
ellos nos enseñaron cosas que ninguna
universidad nos podía enseñar
sahil se convirtió en el perfecto
ejemplo sobre optimización como con tan
pocos recursos puedes crear algo tan
hermoso hijita fue la mejor profesora de
superación como en tan sólo seis meses
te puedes convertir en ingeniera solar y
cambiar la vida de muchas personas
después de esto la pregunta fue nosotras
con el conocimiento que tenemos hasta
ahora que hemos hecho y lo más
importante que podemos hacer
y esto nos llevó a buscar experiencias
laborales que nos permitan transformar
todos esos conocimientos de ideas
abstractas en algo más tangible y real
bani se fue a nueva york a trabajar en
un start-up de tecnología ella me contó
que estaba rodeada de las personas más
preparadas que había visto en su vida
muchos de ellos ingenieros graduados de
las mejores universidades del mundo me
llamaba emocionadísima todos los días a
contarme que en su trabajo utilizaban
inteligencia artificial para detectar
fraude en las llamadas de teléfono y la
verdad que yo me entendía nada vale por
otro lado se fue a san francisco que es
la meca del emprendimiento y la
innovación y en donde encontramos a
nuestro tercer detonante ella estaba
trabajando para una microfinanciera que
daba préstamos a emprendedores pequeños
ella me contó que todos los martes iba a
oakland una ciudad cerca de san
francisco en donde trabajaba con la
comunidad hispana de emprendedores y en
donde conoció a don raúl un líder de
esta comunidad que le dijo
salida en mi país en busca de un futuro
mejor pero al llegar acá me di cuenta de
lo difícil que iba a ser no conocía el
idioma y no tenía a nadie que me apoye
después de batallar mucho y finalmente
tener éxito en mi primer negocio decidí
dedicar toda mi vida a ayudar a las
personas de mi comunidad pero ella me
también me contó que a pesar de que don
raúl trabaje día y noche para llegar al
mayor número de personas posible el reto
de encontrar financiamiento para los
emprendedores latinos sigue siendo un
gran problema y después de esto yo no
podía dejar de pensar a cuántas personas
más don raúl podría ayudar si tendría
acceso a las ideas o la tecnología que
se estaba utilizando en mi trabajo o
mejor aún cuántos de los problemas más
grandes del mundo podríamos resolver si
uniremos la sabiduría de líderes locales
que ya estaban en contacto con esos
problemas y tenían la solución con redes
globales y el poder transformativo de la
tecnología después de esto no nos
queríamos quedar con los brazos cruzados
que decidimos actuar y regresar a
nuestro país y esto nos lleva de vuelta
al 12 de enero del 2018 a punto de dar
el discurso de apertura de un evento una
invento llamada wake que fue planeado
para crear preguntas para hacer ese
detonante el primero de los tres pasos
para despertar un evento que busca unir
soñadores locales con oportunidades y
una red de contactos global
queremos encontrar conaway a esas
personas despiertas que ya hayan vivido
este proceso de reflexión y que como
acción coherente están creando empresas
que tienen el potencial de resolver
varios problemas en el país y un ejemplo
perfecto de esto es david un joven de
tulcán que conocimos gracias a wake
davín después de un dolor fuertísimo de
estómago a las 5 de la mañana y al estar
consciente que en el ecuador la mayoría
de gente no tiene acceso a servicios
básicos de salud instantáneos decidió
actuar y crear muy multi doctores una
plataforma en línea que resuelve este
problema
ahora la pregunta del millón porque
despertar levante la mano al que le
costó levantarse hoy de su cama si
estamos tan cómodos dormidos en nuestra
rutina por qué molestarse en salir de
esa comodidad uno de nuestros libros
favoritos una nueva tierra del cartón
tiene una excelente explicación sobre la
importancia de ser personas conscientes
llevémoslo a la conciencia a un nivel
microscópico un nivel celular una célula
inconsciente de su función en el
organismo se empieza sobre producir y
termina matando al mismo cuerpo que le
da la vida
este fenómeno es muy bien conocido en el
campo de la medicina como cáncer lo
mismo pasa a un nivel macro a veces como
individuos nos olvidamos de la
interconectividad del mundo vivimos
dormidos en nuestras rutinas sin darnos
cuenta que conscientes o inconscientes
nuestras acciones van a afectar a los
demás y al final a nosotros mismos y si
estamos conscientes un pequeño detonante
como un dolor de barriga a las cinco de
la mañana pueden convertirse en ese
primer paso para ayudar a muchas
personas
y al final esta charla no es sobre
nuestra historia personal sino sobre
como todas las personas nos ayudaron a
entender que nuestras acciones están
conectadas a algo más grande más
trascendental es la historia sobre un
cambio de conciencia un cambio de
mentalidad que nos ayuda a ver la
interconectividad entre todos los seres
humanos y entender que el mundo
verdaderamente es una aldea global la
buena noticia es que no tenemos que
viajar a ningún lugar lejano graduarnos
de una universidad ni mucho menos tener
una gemela para vivir este proceso
cuando menos te lo esperas la vida te
sorprende y te pone a personas o
situaciones que se van a convertir en
esa primera chispa para encontrar o
empezar este proceso de despertar pero
tenemos que estar dispuestos a vivir un
constante proceso de cuestionamiento
reflexión y acción coherente
porque solo al estar despiertos y
conscientes nuestras acciones se pueden
transformar en herramientas que generan
cambios positivos en cuenca en ecuador y
en el mundo gracias
[Aplausos]